alors une grande journée de mobilisation
en pleine crise du coronavirus de la
colère dans un contexte sanitaires qui
se dégradent alors est-ce que vos
moments pour battre le pavé cela peut-il
payer et bien on va en parler tout de
suite toujours avec notre éditorialiste
alexis poule 1 re bonsoir merci pour
suivre la soirée avec nous et puis pour
commenter cette mobilisation est avec
nous christian saint-etienne économistes
bonsoir et michel monnier ancien
directeur général adjoint de l'unedic
merci à tous les trois alors dans le
contexte que l'on connaît contexte
sanitaire très compliqué est ce que
finalement c'est un succès cette
mobilisation aujourd'hui pour les
organisateurs selon vous alexis poulain
qu'est ce que vous avez observé
aujourd'hui on a observé des syndicats
qui étaient tous là avec vous un nombre
limité à assemblement limitée obligeant
qu'ovide obligeant mais au moins sur des
revendications claires sur la hausse de
salaires la protection de l'emploi les
choses qui sont nécessaires aujourd'hui
compte tenu de la crise dans laquelle
nous sommes et qui va te faire
qu'empirer le problème c'est que j'ai
peur que les syndicats ne soient pas
forcément en ordre de bataille ou équipe
et quand j'entends monsieur martinez
parlait de l'europe sociale qu'il
faudrait faire ça fait des années qu'on
attend cette europe sociale et la
présidente de la commission européenne
von der leyen dans son discours hier n'a
pas fait état comme une priorité des
priorités de créer une harmonisation
sociale au sein des états européens donc
là on a un problème parce que cette
compétition de tous contre tous
continuent et puis on voit des syndicats
comme la cfdt de laurent berger qui le
favorise des mesures de primes pour les
ménages plutôt que d'avoir des
augmentations de salaires pérenne donc
il faudrait se mettre d'accord et puis
vraiment se battre pour pour les
salaires et pour la protection de
l'emploi est encore une fois on a vu à
la façon dont ils étaient dans la rue
seront ils entendus quand on a un
ministre d'économie comme bruno le maire
qui à part fustigé a pas retrouvées
révoltant le fait que les entreprises
pour ce qu'elles veulent puisqu'elles
peuvent le faire elles prennent des
subventions et puis s'en vont et on va
vivre le pire de la mondialisation c'est
à dire que l'emploi quand ils dépendent
entreprises internationales de
deux multinationales il est extrêmement
volatil parce qu'elles peuvent jour au
lendemain ferme une usine et choisir
d'ouvrir l'activité ailleurs et ça le
politique n'y peut rien peu importe les
postures la communication qui va être
fait
on va rentrer dans le dur et ça va être
extrêmement difficile et compliqué pour
le politique de trouver des solutions
pour sauver les emplois
voilà michel monnier on entend la verte
d'alexis poulain est ce que vouloir
partager et est ce que au fond basse et
le moment en pleine crise sanitaire pour
les syndicats de faire entendre leur
voix aujourd'hui selon vous ce qui s'est
passé au jour d'aujourd'hui était de
toute façon annoncé avant la crise il
faut que nous nous souvenions qu'il y
avait ce type de mouvements bar qui
résultait des discussions en cours sur
sur la réforme des retraites
depuis il s'est passé quelque chose
d'assez remarquable c'est que pour la
première fois on a mis en sommeil
l'économie pendant deux mois mettant
sommeil l'économie pendant deux mois il
a fallu ressortir formulé de cette façon
mais les vieilles recettes on ressortir
tous les dispositifs de notre modèle de
protection sociale et pour répondre à
cette situation avec notamment
alors qu'il était question de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage avec notamment un
système d'un dispositif de chômage
partiel qui a été particulièrement doux
paix est d'autant plus dopé compare
aujourd'hui de chômage partiel de longue
durée
alors est ce que c'est le moment pour
poser ces questions là je dirais que
c'est le moment pour poser la question
de ce que doit être notre modèle de
protection sociale
aujourd'hui le modèle économique change
certains lui disent mondialisée trop
mondialisée certains le disent libéral
trop libérale
ce qu'il nous faut observer c'est que me
semble que c'est aussi pour la première
fois on entend dire que l'économie
française se relèverait plus rapidement
que certaines de ces des économies
voisines
justement on peut à ce sujet
demandez à un autre économiste christian
saint-etienne donc une économie
fortement dopé de nous rappelait michel
monier à cause de la crise sanitaire
est ce qu'aujourd'hui la france a pu se
relever est ce que ça peut être l'un des
premiers pays à pouvoir se relever de
cette crise selon vous si oui pourquoi
bon la crise est quand même très
profondes dont notamment parce que la
france est spécialisée dans des domaines
qui sont particulièrement frappés par la
crise
on pense à l'aérien et au tourisme qui
sont des secteurs tout à fait massif
dans notre économie
la culture aussi toutes les activités
culturelles les festivals tout cela donc
quand on regarde le fonctionnement de
notre économie nous avons davantage
plongée que les allemands au printemps
mais c'est lié à la durée de du
confinement puisque nous avons confiné
de manière assez dur pendant quasiment
deux mois quand les allemands n'ont
vraiment fermé et que partiellement
pendant un mois
mais effectivement on a été agréablement
surpris en juillet-août de la remontée
de l'économie parce que dès les français
sont partis en vacances chez eux et donc
ils ont partiellement remplacé les
touristes étrangers mais le secteur de
l'aviation ne repart pas lavier tout à
l'heure la des gens qui étaient
interviewés et qui se dé grève dans les
aéroports
mais on est parent pesanteur quand le
trafic aérien baisse de 70 ou 80% et que
les rythmes de production de l'airbus
baisse de moitié
il est clair que ça va affecter l'emploi
là est ce que l'économie française
pourrait rebondir encore plus vite en
il ya quand même une question parce
qu'on a fait parler assez longtemps les
salariés watch stone
on l'a dit à juste titre que les clés
[Musique]
politique faisait un peu de vent et
qu'il n'avait pas d influence réelle sur
les situations sociales
il y aurait donc je suis très surpris
dont on ne parle pas c'est quand même la
politique commerciale européenne parce
que la réelle raison de la fermeture de
cette usine dans le nord de la france à
béthune
c'est le fait que les chinois sont en
train d'inonder le marché européen de
matic
ils sont en train de refaire dans cette
filière de production ceux qui l'ont
déjà fait dans les panneaux
photovoltaîques accueil photovoltaïque
il ya quelques années où ils ont détruit
la la production européenne et on serait
aux états unis dans la même situation
les américains mettra en place des
droits compensateurs dans la mesure où
les chinois produisent beaucoup avec des
subventions d'état
donc il ya quand même un domaine où on
peut vraiment réagir c'est celui de la
politique commerciale commune au niveau
européen on parle depuis trois ans un
peu plus de réciprocité mais on voit
qu'on n'est pas en oeuvre pour compte
encore comment vous comprenez on va
donner la parole à alexis poulain
comment vous comprenez que cette
réciprocité soient pas mises en oeuvre
aujourd'hui on a entendu un bruno le
maire parlait d'une fermeture révoltante
il promet de se battre pour autant ces
mesures de réciprocité pourquoi elles
sont pas prises aujourd'hui en europe
comment vous le comprenez mais parce que
l'europe est empêché par la façon dont
elle a été construite avec ce dogme du
libre-échange de la circulation des
biens et des personnes ou les pays
européens ne sont pas protégés par
l'ensemble européen et sont en
compétition eux mêmes
il faut voir la façon dont on travaille
les allemands eux sont dépendants de
leur commerce extérieur
jean claude juncker avant de partir et
quitter son siège la commission
européenne va prier trump de ne surtout
pas mettre des taxes sur les voitures
allemandes aux états unis mais nous ne
faisons rien nous acceptons tous des
partenaires commerciaux quasiment tous
nous signons des accords de libre
échange qui ne vont pas aider à sauver
les emplois ou pérenniser les emplois en
europe qui vont simplement faire que on
a ra davantage de compétition parce que
in fine est ce que veulent les
institutions européennes c'est que le
consommateur est le meilleur choix ou
plus de choix donc il soit disant que la
concurrence serait la meilleure chose
pour que les prix baissent c'est faux
dans le secteur de l'énergie s'est
faudra beaucoup
acteur et pire encore c'est quelque
chose qui détruit les entreprises
européennes et qui empêche la création
de champions européens dans ces domaines
là et on voit bien là où nous étions
forts l'aéronautique c'est un des
secteurs les plus impactés donc je vois
pas comment airbus va pouvoir s'en
remettre sans des milliards
d'investissements de la part des
partenaires européens et puis encore une
fois quand on parle des deux européennes
dans le plan de relance c'est une aide
assujettis à des réformes structurelles
ça a été encore redit par madame von der
leyen hier j'attends de voir quelles
vont être les réformes en france
puisqu'on parle de continuer sur la
réforme des retraites sur la réforme
bien sûr de la science
d'assurance-chômage flexibilité du
marché du travail tout ça ne va pas
aider la plupart des gens qui vont
perdre leur emploi vous rentrez dans un
monde où la croissance va être molle
très faibles et vont être dans le
chômage pendant longtemps
malheureusement et rien n'est fait du
côté du gouvernement pour éviter
l'entrée dans la précarité
il n'y a pas de plan pour lutter contre
la pauvreté qui va malheureusement
explosé avec cette crise parce que
au-delà des grandes entreprises qui vont
avec le plan financier sauvé quelques
profits et quelques emplois c'est les
tpe pme qui vont le plus souffrir qui
vont mettre la clé sous la porte des
faillites vont être malheureusement
nombreuses et là il n'y a pas de filet
de sécurité et ses 90 % de l'emploi en
france et en europe qui sont dans les
tpe dans les pme et j'ai l'impression
que là encore sur ce plan de relance
c'est l'angle mort de deux du
gouvernement puisque on va aider à la
transition numérique on va aider à plein
de choses mais là on demande à des gens
de faire l'impossible c'est à dire de
continuer l'activité alors qu'il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas de demande il n'y
a pas de croissance est pour et pour eux
il n'y a pas de solution
malheureusement aujourd'hui très clair
très visible michel monnier alexis
poulain on parlait la réforme des
retraites et de l'assurance chômage
était également au coeur des inquiétudes
un jour d'hui alors vu le contexte
économique actuel
est ce que le gouvernement il peut
vraiment prendre la décision selon
gudrun ouvrir le dossier alors que
vraisemblablement l'urgence est ailleurs
galles est votre regard sur cette
situation
je reprends le terme d' urgence que vous
venez d'employés jeu il me semble que la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
issus de cette crise sanitaire permet de
réunir les conditions pour non pas
réformé tel ou tel aspect du modèle de
protection sociale mais pour poser la
question de ce que doit être le modèle
de protection sociale dans l'économie
d'aujourd'hui
parmi les risques que l'on court aurait
quitté cité par mathieu poulin je pense
qu'il y en a un qui se rajoutent dans la
compétition en entre les pays ça va être
la compétition pour la relocalisation
ont fait de la relocalisation de nos
industries un des axes majeurs recréer
de l'emploi pense que certains voisins
vont aussi vouloir entre localiser et
qu'on va se battre pour recréer de
l'emploi que l'on a laissé partir ces
dernières décennies
alors il me semble vraiment que au delà
de manifestations et deux mobilisations
comme celle d'aujourd'hui ou de la
démobilisation comme celle qui se
faisait avant cette crise là petit à
petit et plutôt que de poser une année
la question de la réforme du régime
d'assurance chômage de poser ensuite
celle de la retraite d'avoir posé et
celle de la formation professionnelle
c'est la question globale du dispositif
qu'il faut poser alors qu'on ne se
réfère pas à 1945
au programme du cnr les choses ont
changé le monde a changé
mais la question de la protection
sociale se pose dans les mêmes
conditions ne s'est passé ces 15
dernières années
l'emploi salarié augmente constamment en
france ils augmentent eux peu quand on
regarde comment a augmenté sur une
période de quinze années la création de
valeur le pib
il a été multiplié par deux sur la même
période
l'emploi a augmenté de 17%
on ne peut pas continuer à vouloir ou à
espérer régler le problème d'accès à
l'emploi avec des recettes qui sont
hérités il ya 50 ans le problème doit
être reposer complètement
du coup christian saint-etienne c'est
cette cette idée de recoller relocaliser
finalement l'entend beaucoup ces
derniers temps on l'a vu avec la crise
la crise sanitaire à la question était
au coeur des débats c'est la solution
aujourd'hui pour retrouver une économie
saine ou en tout cas une dynamique scène
pour la france l'a reconnu
relocalisation c'est ça le mot magique
avant de relocaliser il faudrait arrêter
les délocalisations il faut surtout
rappeler que la france a organisé sa
propre désindustrialisation depuis une
vingtaine d'années nous sommes le pays
développés qui s'est le plus d
industrialiser au cours des vingt
dernières années et la part de la
production industrielle dans le pub est
tombé à 10% alors que que l'état 21 % en
allemagne
et ça c'est lié pas seulement 35 heures
même si ça démarre à partir de 2002
manière extrêmement brutal c'est tout ce
processus de désindustrialisation
c'est lié au fait qu'au cours des années
90 les élites françaises aussi bien
politiques de droite et de gauche que
écologique
on se souvient de chuck qui disait en
début de l'an 2000 qu il voulait une
entreprise sans usine alors il a
totalement réussi
il ya plus d usines mais il ya plus
d'entreprises non plus donc il a dirigé
un groupe alcatel alstom à l'époque qui
aurait pu devenir le samsung français et
il reste plus que des petits morceaux
donc la question centrale c'est pour
favoriser la relocalisation il faut une
politique d'ensemble sur la la
localisation de l'industrie alors
souvent on dit mais ça ne dépend pas que
de nous prenons un secteur où c'est
l'état qui achètent et ce secteur c'est
l'assurance maladie qui achètent les
médicaments qu'est ce qu'on fait depuis
20 ans
nés tous les ans pour réduire le trou de
la sécu on baissent très fortement les
prix des médicaments
nous avions une industrie du médicament
qui était la deuxième d'europe douzaine
d'années mais qui tombe y est tombé au
cinquième rang avec des délocalisations
massives dont six par ailleurs au cours
de la crise on s'est rendu compte que 70
% des bases qui permettent de faire les
médicaments venaient de chine et d'inde
c'est quand même hallucinant et moi je
ne comprends pas si je vais je l'avais
dénoncé déjà avant la crise du coc vide
je ne comprends pas pourquoi l'état
acheteurs de médicaments n'est pas une
politique sur le thème vous serez mieux
remboursés si ces produits en france si
les bases viennent d'europe voilà donc à
partir du moment où l'on considère que
l'industrie c'est secondaire
ballet des fermetures d'usinés comme
celle de ben études vont continuer on a
fermé 2000 dans les 15 dernières années
d'autant plus que la police la
désindustrialisation en france comme je
le disais précédemment accompagne le
système européen où on a une politique
commerciale sans réciprocité
juste un mot sur conclura ensuite il
nous reste quelques secondes sur cette
politique commerciale sans réciprocité
faut bien comprendre que les américains
autant que les chinois d'ailleurs font
ce qu'ils veulent en europe mais que
nous ne pouvons pas par exemple avoir
des entreprises en pleine propriété en
chine
donc on n'arrive pas à se développer de
façon les marchés publics chinois sont
fermés alors que les chinois avant ou
peuvent pénétrer les marchés européens
et j'évoquais tout à l'heure leur
politique de visant à détruire des
filières aujourd'hui les pneumatiques et
hier c'était le photovoltaïque
donc s'il n'y a pas une vraie une double
réponse au niveau français avec une
vraie volonté de réindustrialiser au
niveau européen avec une vraie volonté
de protéger le marché unique contre la
prédation extérieur ben les les luttes
sociales et les fermetures d'usinés vont
continuer
temps merci beaucoup christian
saint-etienne un dernier mot pour
conclure alexis poulain qu'est ce que ça
dit tout ça ça dit que depuis des années
nos technocrates énarque etc ont
organisé la faillite industrielle de la
france et de l'europe en grande partie
est pourquoi parce que on a refusé la
planification on a refusé aussi de faire
de l'europe un outil de protection un
marché commun oui c'était tout et ça
n'allait pas plus loin
aujourd'hui on voit que françois bayrou
est nommé au plan mais c'était un faux
plans puisque c'est simplement gérer un
peu le plan de relance mais pour ce qui
est de la planification et on le voit
d'ailleurs dans la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
on est encore loin du compte il faudrait
peut-être commencer à réfléchir à avoir
un vrai commissariat au plan pour ce qui
va être des relocalisations grand merci
à tous les trois pour votre décryptage
votre analyse merci avoue christian
saint-etienne rappelle que vous êtes
économiste
merci à vous michel monnier ancien
directeur général adjoint de l'unedic et
merci à alexis poulain éditorialistes